we're just going to come out and say it
we miss you Kelly Highlands we were
super shocked when you got into that
physical altercation with Abby Lee
Miller but we won't deny that she pushed
her buttons it was so sad to see Paige
and Brooke go but they're doing a lot
better now that they've put the show
behind them it was obvious that Abby
didn't want them around and that Paige
and Brooke were done with dancing so you
did the right thing by leaving and you
certainly went out with a bang I'm just
tired so what has happened in the first
eight seasons of Dance Moms from mommy
meltdowns to fights to everything in
between but did you know that some
secrets were deemed too radical for the
reality TV series to broadcast keep
watching to find out which parents put
their kid in harm's way for fame the guy
with the dojo tattoo
Jojo C WA is one of the most influential
teenagers of the decade she has a large
following of diehard fans who would wait
long hours in line to shake her hand or
get an autograph the one of JoJo's fans
takes things to the next level which
resulted in him being thrown in jail for
a total of three years back in 2015
five suspicious packages were sent to
the ALDC via the post office but
officials immediately sense that
something was wrong so they alerted the
bomb squad but when the parcels were
deemed safe enough to open officials
found something equally as disturbing as
it turns out a 36 year old male had sent
dodo packages filled with extremely
explicit material and its contents were
so disturbing that it shook officers to
the core to make matters worse the
culprit also had a YouTube channel in
which he addressed the girls at the ALDC
in a totally inappropriate manner the
stalker was so obsessed with Jojo that
he even got a portrait of the young star
tattooed on his body officers tried
their best to keep the ordeal under
wraps but the cat got out of the bag
anyway and
this next scene isn't as disturbing as
the first one but it does prove that The
Dance Moms is far from being the reality
TV show it pretends to be one of the
most impressive things about the ALDC is
how quickly its dancers learn their
routines and how despite their short
windows of preparation time the girls
always seem to perform their routines
flawlessly well it was soon revealed
that the dance competitions were filmed
multiple times to guarantee perfection
unless of course executives wanted the
girls to fail so that they can
manipulate the storylines Dance Moms
executives would get the girls to
perform the routines a handful of times
before yelling cut suddenly the aldc's
flawless competition record seems like a
total sham Kyra's run-in with the law
being a famous TV personality might seem
like a dream come true but living in the
spotlight makes it all the more
challenging to keep the past in the past
despite her greatest efforts Kyra
Gerard's past came back to haunt her
when her criminal record became public
knowledge back in 2005 long before Kira
took the stage as a dance mom she was
arrested for partaking in theft and
fraud schemes from July to October of
2005 Kira made over $15,000 by posting
fake TV ads on eBay the future reality
TV star would accept money transfers
from unsuspecting victims who believed
that a plasma TV was going to be sent to
their residents when Kira's home was
raided officers found proof that Kira
was behind these fraudulent activities
but she denied them every step of the
way
eventually Kira admitted to the crime
and was fined and given two years of
probation unfortunately she never
completed her 400 hours of community
service which resulted in her receiving
an even larger probationary sentence
jojo's of Burnett's it's no secret that
the moms of Dance Moms enjoyed living in
the limelight sure their daughters are
talented dancers who deserve to get
recognized but that's never stopped the
moms from using their daughters to rise
to the top one of Jo Joshua's most
notable traits is her long blonde hair
so you can just imagine how shocked her
fans were when they found out that Jojo
was a natural
Net Jojo was only 11 years old when she
joined the cast of Dance Moms and many
parents would agree that bleaching your
eleven-year-old daughter's hair is sort
of absurd but that never stopped
jessalyn Sela from causing permanent
damage to her young daughters locks so
she could come off as a natural blonde
Joslin received a lot of scrutiny for
her actions and for good reason too
after all it isn't safe to put bleach on
a child's scalp there's nothing wrong
with being a brunette but dojo still
feels the need to bleach her hair to
keep her image going strong Paige's
lawsuit it's no secret that Abby Lee
Miller always had a problem with Paige
and Brooke Hyland and their mother Kelly
but when things got physical between
Kelly and Abby the Hyland's quickly left
the cast and never looked back
but just when Abby thought that she had
the Hyland's out of her hair Paige
filled a lawsuit against her former
teacher the lawsuit claims that Abby
abuse page causing her extreme emotional
distress as many of us know Paige
suffered a handful of anxiety attacks
while on the show and according to her
abby was to blame for these episodes
despite the highlander greatest efforts
their lawsuit was dismissed while the
judge couldn't deny that growing up on
the set of Dance Moms was a stressful
ordeal he dismissed the case because
there wasn't enough proof that Abby
absolutely abused Paige if you loved
Dance Moms as much as we do make sure to
subscribe to the thing so you never miss
another video and don't forget to click
that bell to get notified whenever we
post new content if you're watching on
your phone go to youtube settings and
turn on your notifications this way you
can be the first to sound off in the
comments bankruptcy when the cast of
Dance Moms first agreed to take the
stage they were under the impression
that they were filming a documentary
[Music]
but before long lifetime executives
noticed how much potential the cast had
and chose to turn their project into a
reality TV series since the show wasn't
popular yet the families hardly saw any
return during the first season but as
time went on money started rolling in
which was a welcome surprise for many of
the mothers on the show because well a
handful of them were on the verge of
bankruptcy Abby Lee Miller on the other
hand was already neck deep in debt and
it was later revealed that the dance
teacher had filed for bankruptcy just
ten months before the first episode of
Dance Moms aired although it's hard to
believe the ALDC wasn't as popular then
as it is today in fact
Abby was pinching every penny because
not many customers were interested in
dancing for her studio
Abby owed a whopping 400 K for failing
to pay her real estate taxes so while
she'll never admit it no one needed
Dance Moms more than Abby mommy rejects
Abby might be the face of Dance Moms but
she isn't the one who came up with its
concept the dance teacher often thought
with lifetime executives because of how
controlling they were over her vision on
more than one account
Abby has told students and their mothers
that she could kick them off the show
and replace them just like that but that
isn't exactly true as it turns out
lifetime producers are the ones who call
the shots no matter what so in reality
Abby didn't get to choose which
mother/daughter pairings made it onto
the show no matter how hard she tried
Abby often referred talented dancers to
the show's executives only to have them
veto her picks it didn't matter how
talented the dancers were but rather how
erratic their mothers could be since the
series is equal parts dance and of mommy
drama dancers were rejected based on
their mothers personalities or lack
thereof Kalani's story every dancer on
Dance Moms
wants Abby to give them solos it's
literally what they want most in life
and which kid gets which solo causes the
moms to get into huge fights because
they all feel like their kid deserves to
be in the spotlight
Kalani Hilliker worked extra hard to
land solos and danced her heart out on
stage so she was super shocked when she
watched Dance Moms and found out that
some of her solos never made the cut
in the end the producers chose to omit
Kalani's solo to add some dramatic
flavour to the show now it's no secret
that Dance Moms is heavily edited to
secure sensitive moments but sadly the
girls had to find this out the hard way
cutting ties season seven of Dance Moms
is by far one of the hardest things to
watch and that's partially because
that's when the Lucchese acts left the
show Abby always had a bone to pick with
Christi and Chloe but there were times
when Abby went way too far like when she
made fun of Chloe's medical issue to
make matters worse lifetime executives
edited out her awful comments to protect
the dance teacher from facing backlash
[Music]
but that's all water under the bridge
now what's most shocking however is how
Christine Chloe decided to block several
of their friends on social media the
second they left the ALDC while we
understand why they would block Abby
were surprised that the Lucchese acts
would block the other members of the
cast after all Chloe considered these
girls to be her best friends and Christi
had grown very close with the other moms
too eventually the Lucchese acts
unblocked The Dance Moms members and
made amends but they'll never be as
close as they once were award ceremonies
Dance Moms is loaded with exciting
scenes and amazing dances and one of the
best parts of the show is its many
awards ceremonies it's so fun to see the
girls win awards for their efforts all
the while making their parents and dance
teacher proud but if there's one dark
secret the cast of Dance Moms tried to
keep under wraps it's at the awards
ceremonies are staged not only are the
award ceremonies staged but the
producers of the show chose which
dancers get which titles and sometimes
the real version of the TV version have
entirely different winners that's a wrap
on ten dark secrets the cast of Dance
Moms tried to hide before you go tell us
which seasons of Dance Moms is your
favorite and why in the comments below
thanks for watching the things don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up we'll catch you later